you guys want to read the most
depressing posts ever did you see the
people replying to mashinsky the ceo of
celsius no twitter no
you oh my god have you uh have you
watched coffee's videos on that that
[ __ ] is so crazy dude no i didn't what's
the gist coffee did like an insane job
like just breaking it down i i watched
his both his videos on it like the most
recent ones and
he kind of highlights the
the [ __ ] housery of celsius basically i
mean before i take off on this charlie
are you like familiar with this whole
thing
so i haven't caught up with celsius i
was really involved in the luna one
which is that stable yeah
yeah 100 to zero in a single week people
lost billions their creator just taking
bets on twitter and losing every single
one of them it was beautiful coffee did
a great series on that too yeah yeah i
watched that one that one was
i mean just the scale oh my god of that
like and now i know someone random was
telling me
uh the other day he was like yeah now
there's like rumors that the original
wallet there's a transfer that someone
tracked and basically making it seem
like the guy dokwan stole like billions
and billions of dollars
something along those lines which i
really hope is true because that would
just be just an incredible button on
this whole thing yeah
yeah
yeah and there's like a heist of that
size just just in plain sight
um
but so this
sorry keep going i was just gonna say uh
the saddest part of that is i don't know
if you saw it they tried to launch luna
2.0 and everyone who got scammed in luna
still bought in and it got scammed again
it rugged immediately
bro
come on
i know it was so pathetic have some
self-respect holy [ __ ]
so i think i don't know if celsius is
bigger i don't know how like the market
caps compare but
like celsius
again was sort of the same thing because
it was an interest generating
um platform right so you could earn
yield if you put your crypto there so
everyone thought it was safe it was like
a savings account for that bro and let
me just like a lot of people had like
their entire net worths and kryptos on
celsius because it was generating six
percent or whatever and let me just add
this uh
coffee like you could watch this video
still even if i say this basically he
talked to a guy who kind of did like
some digging
on the mechanisms that celsius was using
to get that yield
and like when you hear some of the [ __ ]
that they did like
honestly it was like giving
imagine like investing in a crypto
company that's like run by your dad who
doesn't understand crypto
like the moves that they were making to
earn the yield were so some of them were
so brain dead it's like crazy
that what were they doing
um
well okay so one of them was
they staked 54 million in like some
random dow
and then the dow got hacked
and so
that dao created like a a like a
a sister coin basically and the whole
premise of it was hey you lost your
money
if you hold these coins we will pay you
back over this period so it'll be like
two or three years or something right
so the people at celsius just decided to
withdraw
all their tokens and when they did that
there was like a very visible like
message that was like part of it that's
like if you do this we will not pay you
back
so they just
they just
sold them all or like they just like
dumped them all for no reason so they
erased like a 54 million dollar
repayment just like that
so funny that every single financial
crime is just being reinvented yeah
we've been through all of this that's
all that's left dude we have nothing
left in this world man
so yeah i guess this is just kind of a
reboot everything's being rebooted now
might as well reboot horrible financial
crimes as well yeah what about to say
charlie is it a token or is it like an
exchange
uh the like the the dow coin or celsius
just celsius in general is it supposed
to be like a like a coin no they had
their own they had their own coin they
did and and that's how like coffee
covers that too that's how like the
the guy mashinsky basically is made off
with a ton of money um
so they had they had their own token but
the whole premise was like what cody was
saying where they were kind of marketing
it like this like
it's a savings account but we're not a
bank but you will make money but we're
not a bank like it's a very yeah because
like so like i said people had their
like they thought it was uh like safe
like i can keep my all my money here and
generate interest and hell yeah dude
this is an awesome way to end the show
this is like a really good final five
minutes let's make this so sad i know
this is heartbreaking but like i know
i'm kind of about like putting this out
there
because i i not like to be on some
whatever but
i think that people should be cautioned
in this way they should be afraid of
investing in crypto because i feel like
not enough people are afraid like the
fact that luna 2.0 had any degree of
success is wildly depressing man
i know
it's so sad like uh when i read these
things
like it's equal parts
it's doesn't sound good to say it's like
entertaining is a spectator sport to
like try and understand it's personal
entertaining i know i know it is and
then you remember it's a real human
being that made this absolutely awful
reckless decision based on twitter [ __ ]
posts
just to picture these people like in a
discord talking with people with like
[ __ ] monkey pictures and [ __ ] and
they're like
nah dude this is definitely going to
make you a bazillionaire this is some
guy like just just some pud on his
laptop who's like okay like just
it's my boy big h he says please don't
let me down i don't mind waiting for my
either i had 45 ethereum which i was
saving for my new house i'm crying and
praying to god that i will be able to
get that money out it took four years
and me working 100 hours every week to
save can't sleep i can't even look into
my wife and kids eyes right now how to
explain and no words can express the
feelings i have
capslock god please help me
jesus
full circle yeah we're having all this
fun pro video games are crazy aren't
they look at these people whose lives
are ruined by crypto look at this misery
[Laughter]
we shouldn't guys it's not funny
it's not funny that this these people
gambled their children's [ __ ] college
fund
go to the next one i can't even read
that one on asscoin dude
it's not funny
holy [ __ ] i just lost 450k girlfriend
lost 400k mom lost 140k sister lost 117.
cousin lost 100k
you're right oh [ __ ] family was rich
though yeah i know yeah they were
falling dude
no flex man
seriously
my dog lost 150k
[Laughter]
now all i have is the 500 grand under my
mattress yeah
yeah all i have is these [ __ ] gold
bars that my family has built our house
on now we have to sell them all
damn dude this is some anime villain
[ __ ] right here your reckless antics
have destroyed my family's financial
security i feel responsible for all of
their losses because i introduced them
to your scam site and trusted you
i mean that's that's a shitty place to
be in man yeah introduce your family to
this thing and they're all like sure
yeah and then they they all lose their
money so they're like what the [ __ ] and
you're like it's not my thing dude
imagine you just go back for
thanksgiving and then they just serve
you a plate and it just has a bullet on
it and they're like you should
[Laughter]
you should leave now
you should leave
well damn
you